accordingly I'm satisfied and fined that
the minimum term of imprisonment which
would have been ordered which would have
been ordered that you serve before
release on license is 29 years
that being lower than the minimum term I
have determined under the Contemporary
regime I set the minimum term as one of
29 years subject to the consideration of
the time he was spent on demand which is
366 days
I remind all of those listening that the
minimum term is just that
a minimum term which cannot be reduced
in any way
after those 29 years have been served
there is no guarantee that you would be
released
it's only if the parole board sides that
you are fit to be released that you will
be released and even then you will be
subject to license and recall if you
breach the terms of your license
David Boyd stand up
for the murder of Nikki Allen on the 7th
of October of 1992 the sentence of the
court is one of life imprisonment you
will serve to 29 years subject to the
366 days which you have spent on demand
before consideration is given to your
release by the parole board
if you take him down